- [Man] One of the
challenges I face all the time
with some of these
students is anxiety.
How I can help them--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man] see that they
can do more than they think
and that they're
stronger than they know.
How would you
articulate or explain to them?
- [Gary] You know how I do it.
I'm doing it. I put
pressure on the true answers.
Insecurity is the seed
that creates all these issues.
- [Man] Absolutely.
- And so I'm
trying to figure out
why they didn't
build self-esteem,
who didn't build self-esteem and
the reason I bring up mom
is like Jesus, it's
such big percentage of it.
Mom or dad is like 80% of it.
It's just, you know, I do
this a lot. I'm fascinated.
Listen, my dad,
I don't talk a lot about this.
That's what happened to my dad.
I'm so impressed by him.
The way my grandmother
parented my dad is unacceptable.
That's the only
word I can think of.
So, I'm fascinated by it
because I had the reverse.
I'm so perfectly
parented by my mother,
I'm unstoppable.
I feel guilty that I'm so
emotionally grounded and strong,
that's why I'm giving it to you.
What do you
think's happening up here?
I feel guilty that
I have it so good mentally.
There's nothing anybody
can do to my mental state.
It's insane.
I am so weird, guys.
(audience laughter)
Nothing hits,
it's like I'm numb.
And so, I go right to the core.
I do it when I see it sometimes.
I'm like, "Hey, you are
unbelievable and you think
"you're shit, that's bad.
"We need to talk about this.
"Tell me everything
about your childhood."
You know?
And I just go there and
sometimes you
get a little break.
But what's really fun is
they start thinking about it
and it changes behavior.
I get an email every day that
says that they disconnected
from somebody in
their inner circle
and for the last six months,
they're breathing for the
first time in their lives.
It is not easy to
break up with your brother.
break up with your spouse.
It is not easy to
break up with your father
but that's
actually the binary move
if they're the
poison of your life.
So, A,
if that's your reality,
you need to think.
'Cause guess what?
You have one life.
And you don't want to be 73 when
your parent passes away
and finally start breathing.
B, if that is not your life,
you need to drive
home right now and
kiss your parents in the face.
(upbeat music)